what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we're gonna
watch visions episode seven today
guys if you like star wars hit the
dislike button i mean the like button
whichever one
also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever our reaction before the next
visions is up full length watch longer
stick with the type code as always over
on our patreon page cover a whole bunch
of shows over there as well for where
you got reaction highlights and watch
alongs included lastly for thumb or
jaden whichever one edited this thanks
thanks a lot
the old person
gramps master i have been meaning to ask
you do you shave any idea how many
planets you've visited so far well you
must hold the jedi record for most
planets visited well i really doubt that
david harbor
for one i was hoping for something a
little more stimulating like maybe more
action it's a lot more peaceful than i
thought it would be
do you sense something
action
i sense a
disturbance in the force
wow what a big d ship you got there man
big ship energy something ancient and
sinister
could it possibly be sith
if so you know i'm ready to fight
it's been hundreds of years since they
were destroyed
so we need to investigate i won't talk
too soon
the only inhabited planet around here is
habbo right have you been there yeah
besides i had a feeling patrolling the
outer rim had to be more exciting than
this
well i got a bad feeling about this yeah
careful what you wish for parker the
view from above was great but
it's even more beautiful planetside
then you should try the local dish
called undo
you'll like it even more sage wisdom as
always
beautiful
oh god this is so cool
the people of this planet are known to
be quite shy why don't i go try to talk
to them first
[Music]
[Laughter]
a couple of days ago an elder from an
unknown tribe visited when he arrived on
his ship he was alone larry elder if
it's this elder he could be hiding his
presence which means that he is close
but it also means he's noticed us
should we head to the mountains then
if we do that we run the risk of missing
him it's safer to stay here and watch
over his ship better idea why don't we
split up
it always works
the mountains are tricky you should get
a guide again so wise i love
harbor's voice i know
so perfect so calming
i wouldn't think an old man could manage
a path like this you've been
underestimating old people all day i
should be one to talk
[Music]
oh he's fine
i've located the old man's starship it
isn't the model i recognize but it
resembles the old sith ships i've seen
in hollows
i'm really hoping that isn't true but
i've got a bad feeling
there's a vanguard carcass
be safe
i'm gonna go fight the carcass it
appears the vampire has been cut down
this was definitely done by a lightsaber
you should head back then he's sure to
be a dangerous opponent
no
oh he's a tiny elder
a jedi
oh my god
no then are you a sister let's not speak
with our mouths
[Music]
oh boy
oh
i sense someone strong in the force but
it's not you must be the other
i won't be as easily defeated as a
vampire i certainly hope not
nope
[Music]
no
[Music]
elder battle
shouldn't have let them split up man
love the rain
oh you little citizen creep you
[Music]
oh
cool
hoo
oh
oh hell yeah
that's the coolest
the badass moment
no no
oh
he couldn't win against the weakness
that comes with age no matter how
powerful you become
no will not last forever
i am also becoming weaker and you shall
continue to get stronger for that is the
way of the galaxy you think i'll get
stronger
quite possibly
buzz off
you why kids
[Music]
piss on it
take that just sith bastard
cool nice
another good one man i'm like pretty
great
that might be the coolest jedi kill i've
ever seen
all right cool let's shoot a chat
another great episode another solid one
uh
felt like cl i love how much i played on
classic samurai yeah absolutely very
much so in every way even like the
badass grandpa or elder type yeah he's
so experienced that his age barely seems
to matter yeah yeah
uh and everything here seemed to be like
metaphor proverb lessons like all the
dialogue exchange seemed to just inhabit
that and i i thought the voiceover work
especially by harbor brought so much
more extra dimension to the character
because while you don't get a lot of
dialogue exchanges that seems to be
truly like character based or really
understanding them under uh to that
degree
still feels like you're getting some
character
especially because of the voice over
word that they got like both of them did
such a great job but especially harbor
that you feel the history of it all like
what i thought that especially when
harvard brought so great to it with his
voice over working this might be the
first time i'm really talking a lot
about a character's voiceover um but i
thought he brought so great to it is
that by the time you get to here where
uh the ending point when talking about
age and how it's inevitable
even though you know yeah palpatine to
know how to clone themselves soul
transfer or whatever the hell it is um
that
you could feel sort of that weariness
on him throughout this whole performance
you know
that that effect of age seems to be
really imbued in his whole performance
throughout so that's why i thought uh
his voiceover work especially felt
incredibly fleshed out
um but yeah like the mood that strucks
and this struck and the atmosphere uh
through it throughout all of it felt
like classic samurai and uh of course
with another great
uh lightsaber battle at the end here
that's one of the probably gonna be one
of the coolest ones i've done so far in
terms of just yeah like stark
picturesque badassness like that is
definitely gonna stick out in my mind
that one where he just thrusts the hilt
into his chest and turns it on like that
was
one of the most satisfying like badass
star wars moments but yeah i loved how
this is really does feel perhaps out of
all of them the most classic samurai
because it's like you know you start out
and you've got they're just on the road
traveling you know out in space but uh
you know and then they happen upon this
town you know there's some kind of
presence there they need to you know
assess and deal with and then from there
you know they do what they have to do
but you know even though you don't spend
so much time in the town like i like the
thing with the kids you know you see at
least a couple people from afar from
dan's perspective uh and then you sort
of go into the the task at hand and so
yeah it had this very straightforward
but also yeah very classic
samurai sort of feel that didn't feel as
specifically locked into like as the
first episode did like okay we're doing
like a kurosawa movie specifically
you know and uh yeah i love love loved
what david harbor did he just like
there's something about when people are
able to bring a voice performance
especially
and especially an anime where it's like
he is so poised and like
calm
but you can tell that that calmness
comes from years and years of travel
seeing things wisdom earned you know
through trial and error and so yeah he
had
so much presence and i thought it worked
well against the actor playing dan
because you know obviously that
character has the more youthful like
lemmy adam kind of energy and across
this series like we've seen a lot of
master and padawan kind of scenarios or
dynamics but i liked what this one
represented in that you are really for
the most part aside from having you know
this battle with this ancient sith guy
you know you are just kind of with the
two of them going about the day by day
of
what it is that they do
uh yeah i really enjoyed this quite a
bit well even with the old guy you know
there was such um
a zeal for the for the warrior
presence that it fails it feels very
that's the thing's what makes it feel
just a tad bit more
um samurai honored
than even perhaps the first episode to a
certain extent because of the fact that
its villain is all about
just the fighting you know like living
all that keeps this guy alive is
searching for another warrior to take on
you know and that he would want to meet
his death in the in the hands of battle
you know yeah and so that's why i think
this even feels a little bit more
samurai asked more than the first one
because because of that fact like that
one is its own for sure
but that feels like it's riffing on
certain movies a little bit more
specific
and then this one just the qualities
that it presents here
uh and the themes at hand just feels so
like traditional yeah in every in every
sense so i i loved it i thought that he
was that the villain especially was just
so cool he just felt like out of so many
different animes i've seen already
absolutely and even how they brought
that theme back around of it first dan's
the one sitting around being like man i
want some action i'm getting kind of
bored out here and then it circles
around
to the old man being like i want some
action this is kind of boring you know
like give me a challenge she's very
anime yeah absolutely yeah absolutely
bored looking for adventure
in the form of the ultimate fight but i
think what it does brings so good with
character the padawan's name is dan i
believe so yeah uh but what it does
bring with character especially too wood
dan is this guy is
he he's he's anxious he's yearning for
some more action in his life
and then
that desire which is not the path of the
jedi leads him to almost losing his life
and you could feel a changing character
by the end of it though
of after almost losing his life clearly
not being ready for certain ambitious
challenges that lie ahead of him
that he does need to slow down and he
does need to keep in mind with his
training and his pride like to keep his
diligence up there
versus
feeling like you got to go head-on into
fighting all of a sudden i mean when you
feel like you're ready you might not be
ready yeah so you do feel that change in
the character act and the actor i don't
know who played him but the actors voice
over work especially
that okay he's not who he was by the
beginning of this episode you know he's
gonna remember his kindness and training
more so while the dialogue was a little
bit more on the nose just about like
lessons and here's what's going on
um and then like the obvious setup of
let's split up like okay well this is
obviously gonna go terrible um you know
other than that
there are still character-based nuances
underneath the surface that i was able
to at least myself um latch on to that
perhaps that wasn't
super apparent in the dialogue but it's
still there
which uh i think is the art of good
visual storytelling absolutely this is
great this is great visuals as well like
it's another one packed like every
episode even ones that i i'm not as like
personally drawn to as much you know
every episode delivers a different
animation flourish that just makes it
that much cooler you know yeah so i
thought this was beautiful to look at
again and
yeah so far you know what is the seventh
episode yeah the only one i wasn't a
major fan of so far is tattooing rap
city uh that's the only one i'm not not
a big fan of but the other ones have
brought something special and i think to
the galaxy
and i would love to see like this is
another one i'm like man i'd love to see
this character brought to live action
get david harbor to grow all his hair
out yeah get a real skinny
i don't think harvard could play him but
but i like those like
aged weathered super like kind of stoic
anime performances
where uh you know there's not
it's not uh you're not overly emotive
per se but you could feel there's a lot
going on underneath the surface of the
voice so he showed up and i thought
immediately of aizawa from my hero
academia and izawa tiger akashi from
naruto you know so things like that
really do
feel amplified in this universe but guys
what'd you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
thanks for checking us out here we'll
catch you guys soon
[Music]